monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la France est à sec à sec
d'argent à sec d’eau à sec d'électricité
à sec de gaz à sec de nucléaire à sec de
médecins et maintenant à sec de certains
médicaments
spasfon et gaviscon nous cherchons
amoxicilline et paracétamol aussi rare
que le pétrole en cette épidémie de
bronchiolite c'est dramatique ce sont
pourtant des médicaments matures peu
onéreux et essentiel tout au long de
l'année alors ma question monsieur le
ministre de la Santé est aussi simple
qu'elle inquiète les professionnels de
santé et les patients quelle est votre
stratégie pour que la France puisse
retrouver sa souveraineté sur les
produits de santé